so meine Damen und Herren jetzt aber mal
zu den wichtigen Sachen am Mittwoch gab
es in Berlin den sogenannten
krisengipfel-schwein die ist wirklich so
Thema unter anderem der Preisverfall
beim Schweinefleisch darüber hat Julia
Klöckner in ihr Ministerium mit
Betroffenen gesprochen ja hat aber keine
Sau interessiert genauso wichtig wäre
übrigens mal ein Krisengipfel Huhn ja
überfällig wäre der denn obwohl der
Fleischkonsum in Deutschland insgesamt
zurückgeht futtern wir tatsächlich immer
mehr Hühnchen von Jahr zu Jahr mehr und
auch die Preise purzeln da weiter
über ein Kilo für nur zwei Euro 89 für
100 Gramm 15 Cent das macht umgerechnet
für 100 Gramm nur 26 Cent ich erwähnt
immer wieder für 100 Gramm 15 Cent man
muss kein Mathematiker sein und zu
erkennen das ist
ja
astreine Problembeschreibung von der
Frau Klöckner und ich sag mal wenn Sie
jetzt noch was dran ändern würde könnte
man fast von Politik sprechen im Juni
ist übrigens ihr staatliches Tierwohl
Label sang und klanglos und
wahrscheinlich endgültig geplatzt aber
meine gut dass wir ein paar Jahre
darüber geredet haben und auch über die
sogenannte Tierwohl Abgabe wird hier
immer nur diskutiert damit wächst die
Verantwortung der Verbraucher sie
müssten das teure Fleisch tatsächlich
kaufen und ihre Essgewohnheiten ändern
ach so ja dann wird das leider nichts
mit dem Tierwohl schade liebe Tiere zwar
wünschen sich 92% der deutschen mehr
Fleisch aus besserer Haltung aber in der
Praxis greifen wir eben doch lieber zum
billighuhn Hühnchen ist ja gesund denkt
man weil es weiß ich nicht weil es kein
Schwein ist und während wir also immer
mehr davon wegschnabulieren verschwinden
gleichzeitig die kleinen
Geflügelbetriebe im Land knallhart
verdrängt vom f in Bayern der
gefiederten Branche von der PHW Gruppe
ja da sagt Ihnen wahrscheinlich nichts
und das ist kein Wunder denn wir reden
hier vom unbekanntesten fast
Monopolisten Deutschlands mit zum
Imperium gehört unter anderem Wiesenhof
die wiederum kennen sie als Werder
Bremen Sponsor und wegen dem hier
man ist das eine Wurst
ja genau das hat sich die Wurst bei den
Dreharbeiten auch gedacht wie groß ist
die Marktmacht dieser PHW Gruppe dazu
haben zwei Kollegen von der Süddeutschen
gerade aufwendig recherchiert und dabei
festgestellt dass sich die ph.w Gruppe
extrem ungern hinter die Stalltüren
gucken lässt also wirklich sehr sehr
scheu diese broilerbarone aber sagen wir
mal so mächtig sind Sie in jedem Fall
die PHG Gruppe hat heute ungefähr 50
Prozent der
geflügelfleischproduktion liegt dann
ihren Händen wenn man sich anguckt was
der nächstgrößere Wettbewerber hat der
hat 15 Prozent ja das ist Marktmacht der
nächstgrößere nur 15 Prozent man nennt
die prw Gruppe nicht umsonst die messst
das of the Universe die kontrollieren
alles vom Küken bis zur Schlachtung dazu
bekommen die Bauern noch das Futter die
Arzneimittel und manchmal sogar den Hof
gestellt also es sei denn Tierschützer
Film irgendwelchen Horror auf solchen
Höfen dann sagt die paw ja das können
wir denn für unsere Subunternehmer haben
wir noch nichts mit zu tun das meiste
was da heimlich gedreht wird können wir
Ihnen zu Hause so kurz nach ihrem
Abendbrot gar nicht zeigen Sachen wie
Massen von Tieren auf engstem Raum Fett
gemäste den dreckigen stellen und wer
schwächelt wird von Peter lustigs bösen
Bruder schon mal lebend in die Mülltonne
geschmissen
schlimmste löwenzahnfolge aller Zeiten
kontrolliert werden solche Betriebe von
den Veterinärämtern der Landkreise was
ja suboptimal ist keine gute Idee weil
so Kreise halt Steuereinnahmen und
Arbeitsplätze brauchen klassischer
Interessenskonflikt offensichtlich ist
die prw-gruppe insgesamt sehr gut
vernetzt denn die Politik hat sich
selten bis gar nicht eingemischt ist da
überhaupt mal was passiert in den
letzten Jahren schon 2011 dokumentierten
tierrechtsaktivisten die Zustände in
dieser Wiesenhof haben der Betroffene
Landwirt reagierte und verriegelte die
bis dahin offenstehenden Türen ja siehst
du wer das schon mal geregelt bzw
verriegelt tatsächlich gibt es unter den
rund 1000 Wiesenhof Betrieben gerade mal
ja 30 sogenannte privathöfe wo es die
Hühner schöner haben die kann man dann
bei Bedarf der Presse zeigen aber klar
am Ende heißt die Hühner Endstation
meist
von Wiesenhof
wer war er noch mal
der größte Schatz der PHW Gruppe ist der
genbauplan eines ganz besonders
fleischbringenden megamastums namens
Ross 308 entwickelt von der EW Gruppe
vorsicht nicht die prw-gruppe das sind
zwei völlig verschiedene Gruppen wir
haben nichts miteinander zu tun also
außer dass die Gründer Geschwister sind
aber sonst nichts wir schalten mal live
ins gehen Labor der EW Group dort
arbeitet Sebastian pufpaff an neuen
hochleistungshühnern der puffpaff was
ist da ihr Jobprofil
Jobprofil sagen wir so wir von der EW
Group erfinden das gemeine Huhn völlig
neu wir machen super Hühner der Homo
sapiens hat sich in letzter Zeit
evolutionär ja gar nicht mehr
weiterentwickelt im Gegenteil ernährt
sich eher mehr und mehr der Amöbe wieder
an aber beim Huhn da gibt es noch
Hoffnung ich sage nur Rost 308 klingt
nach Pferd ist aber genetisch das beste
Huhn der Welt das ist so ein geiles Huhn
ist das hier der wirklich so manche
Frauen eine dicke Scheibe von
abschneiden
abschneiden kein Huhn ist ja was zu
essen
was kann denn Rost 308
es wird super schnell Fett im Grunde
genommen das Gegenteil von Biggest Loser
fünf Wochen nach dem Schlüpfen wiegen
die Uschis 1,5 Kilo
vor allem an der Brust haben sie
unglaublich zugelegt nur damit sie mal
Vergleich haben bei uns Menschen würde
das bedeuten dass ein Baby mit 3,5
Kilogramm Geburtsgewicht nach fünf
Wochen ungefähr
140 Kilogramm wiegen würde krass oder
140 Kilogramm oder wie amerikanische
Kinder gerne sagen
Einschulung die super Hühner müssen nach
fünf Wochen geschlachtet werden weil die
wegen der fetten Brust sonst immer nach
vorne fallen moderne Landwirtschaft
nimmt immer das Gute von Frankenstein
und geht noch weiter schauen Sie sich
mal unsere
Hochleistungskühe an guck mal sowas
siehst du sonst nur wenn sich Onkel
Günther am FKK-Strand bügt
yummy oder immer nach dem Motto höher
schneller Euter verstehe sie spielen im
Grunde Gott Quatsch gott ruft bei mir an
und fragt ob beim Praktikum machen kann
und die ph-wroup bietet ja noch so viel
mehr als nur fette Hühner da gibt es das
Gesamtpaket inklusive Tierarztbehandlung
schon die Küken werden vollgepumpt mit
Antibiotika an das geht nämlich nicht so
wie wir die halten sterben die Hühner
sonst wie die Igel auf der Landstraße
das Ergebnis auf fast allen Hähnchen
sind
Antibiotika-resistente Keime sowohl bei
Bio als auch bei Konvent
ja aber das ist doch fair Keime nicht
nur für arme Discounter Penner sondern
auch für den Kieferchirurgen der mit dem
Q7 zum bioladenbrettert und denkt er
wäre sicher vor keinem
so ein Opfer ja das klingt ziemlich fair
nun ist es aber leider so dass Mediziner
seit 20 Jahren waren wenn wir weiter
sogar Reserve Antibiotika in der
Tiermast verballern dann erwischt uns
irgendwann der große superkeim
ja das ist ein Dilemma keine Frage
billig Huhn oder Überlebende Menschheit
was ist wichtiger maße ich mir nicht an
außerdem wäre doch schön wenn die
nächste Pandemie mal nicht aus China
kommt sondern aus Deutschland wo sind
wir denn sonst noch Weltspitze deshalb
wir forschen weiter nach Rost 308 kommt
wahrscheinlich Rost 3.09 30 10 8 20 ich
will nicht zu viel verraten das wird der
Hammer hier ganze feine ganze feine ist
sie oder gestern erst geschlüpft leute
lasst mal das Huhn durch
Sebastian Puffer vielen Dank
naja genau ja die Zuschauer mittlerweile
fast alle versteckten Symbole hier bei
uns im neuen Studio gefunden
Illuminati Freimaurer Staatsfunk ist
alles dabei wann wollen wir denn die
eigentlichen Strippenzieher bekanntgeben
es bei so vielen Abonnenten auf Youtube
boah also ich würde mich ranhalten